Shh like you're a little more snappier
in people yes I was you know because it
was a new world for me because it for me
was like if you're gonna talk [ __ ] then
get ready cuz I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna hold it in like we're gonna have a
[ __ ] battle but you've never been to the
fist fight before I've never been in
debt I've always wanted you to fight
somebody I've always wanted to fight
somebody I don't know about now like I
feel like I've expired like my age like
it just stopped well what you wish you
have a business that you have like a
name to yourself you can't go walk
around slapping the [ __ ] out of people
it doesn't work that way you just I'd
take the L like consistently I think
there are many times if I was younger
but you know I probably would have stood
up and said something and might have
gotten my ass beat I'm gonna talk about
my hair now your hair looks like you
gotta fight with the weed whacker and
laughs my friend you know but now I just
chase me quiet and then just walk away
from me I don't think I've ever been in
a situation recently at least where I
felt like I was threatened enough or
annoyed enough or pushed into a corner
and that's also because you're very
recluse like you don't go out so you
don't put yourself in situations where
you can find somebody to piss you off so
if you go out more I guarantee you you
are going to get pissed 10 times more
often like I do because there's always
something that happens yeah like I
didn't fight with my siblings or
anything because there's like such a
huge age gap but the one time I got to
fight with my sister which was like I
was probably like nine and she was
whatever plus 15 is Adam do math I tried
I really did try maybe because I'm a
[ __ ] gargantuan they were like Hema
no not down I think she was older you
know
like she came she like grew up like in
the hood the way I did but she was like
in a gang so oh [ __ ] yeah yeah so really
you're just wasn't a game yeah she was
in a gang I don't remember the name of
the gang but she was in a game for a
little bit last to eat those burritos
yeah they call it a little oka I don't
really know no K I'm about to say cuz it
sounds [ __ ] real to me right now
no I mean she only has a tear drop next
to her eye but I mean we don't talk
about that anything she has a shirt on
right now I can't because like you're
just building this world in my head so
what what type of person would you
prefer uh in high school I always feel
like I didn't belong in high school like
I always felt like everyone around me
was super immature
oh so you're one of those guys I wasn't
I wasn't no I was super introverted like
I was just kind of like to myself a lot
I really hope you weren't one of those
girls that look like I can't hang out
with these people because I'm Way too
mature for that you're like I'm like an
older person at a government percent
ability no [ __ ] hated not at all no
no not at all I just felt low super
geeky and like out of place all the time
but I just felt like the problems and
the [ __ ] that people were talking about
around me I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
so you cannot intercept maybe up and
tell you this though so when I was going
to church there was girl I will not sit
let's just call her
rhymes with Elaine let's call her Elaine
so her name's Elaine Noel you laid right
so mind you like I was a church kid and
this girl had this concept of herself as
if she was like holier than thou like
for her like what she gave me with us
we're the same age she's not like she
was the adult but first of all watch
same a um no yeah first of all [ __ ] we
the same [ __ ] age you came up a [ __ ]
the same time I came out of a [ __ ] you
ain't nobody right and so we are our
Bible study teacher showed up late one
time and that she no joke this [ __ ]
holier-than-thou [ __ ] website
our Bible she was you know what class
today I'm the Bible study oh you better
pray to God that there is a God cuz you
about to see him in a couple of seconds
you said that to her I was like what the
[ __ ]
and literally actually pulled out a
Bible I said immediately I was like no
you wouldn't I said that's all I said he
analyzes at this yes I did
okay still wearing the button-up flannel
you know I was wearing a white t-shirt
with ketchup stains nice were you hungry
were you like this size bigger no I was
always the size okay and I was telling
like straight up no you are not giving
me a [ __ ] Bible study lesson one of
these huh I said no and then she goes
listen like I feel like this is what I'm
here for
as if it was manifest destiny yeah
that's the [ __ ] Bible studies she
just showed up five minutes late
like [ __ ] sit your dumb ass down let me
tell you something right now I know
you're I wish you go to hell I hate that
girl no I like your stories because then
like
you hate me on like especially when it
comes to gossip time unlike us why she
what she did what you're like I know
gossip is the [ __ ] though but here's the
thing though my gossip isn't very
interesting because I don't gossip about
people that normally you know it's not
always outside the circle so you there's
no way you can and so it's not the
circle that you know no I don't know you
don't want to [ __ ] up other people's
information so those two worlds that
always gossip about it's like completely
separate from your world and you'll
never meet them ever what do you say
about us I say great things about you I
don't ever tell me I don't ever so on
camera I specifically I hate me I know I
always say nice things about you Wow
give me three let's go okay thanks okay
fine one you're tall you're guys and you
got legs
did you tell people yeah geo my friend
she's so tall with eyes and a big big
ass legs how naughty what you are told
them